[Music]
[Music]
ecuadorian special forces
storm a maximum security prison in the
country's south
[Music]
pizza pizza
they shout at the inmates to get on the
ground
and fire tear gas in a bid to bring the
riot under control
[Music]
inmates are seen covering themselves
from the choking fumes
while others are arrested
there's a chase as some of the prisoners
attempt a jailbreak
this dramatic video was released today
after riots broke out in three
prisons within these wars
rival gangs have turned on each other in
a battle for power and leadership
some fought with handmade weapons others
reportedly beheaded dozens of people
have been killed
the police and military remains
stationed outside waiakea letaconga and
cuenca
there are frequent riots and violence in
ecuador's prison system
but this has so far been the deadliest
i want my son out because he could get
killed the authorities want to hand him
over dead
no my son has asked me to get him out
because they want to kill him
i don't know anything about my son i was
sent a message
yesterday on the phone he always uses to
communicate and it said only we are all
locked up
that's it i sent another message but i
didn't receive a response
many worried that their loved ones
remain in danger
with gang disputes regularly spilling
into violence
inside the prison wars laura berdimani
al jazeera